so today I would like you to talk about
zero knowledge proof so the reason why I
would like to talk about that is that
today there are a lot of useful
technologies coming out so more and more
technologies are very graves but I have
the big drawback that they need your
data and your data can actually be
pretty private or sensitive in that
scope to leave privacy enhancing
technologies aims to let you have both
so you can benefit from modern
technologies without having to give back
your data or on the other way around you
can have your privacy without having to
go back to the Stone Age for instance a
nice example of privacy enhancing
technologies is the zero knowledge proof
and it's the thing I'm going to talk
about you today what actually is you
knowledge proof are they are protocol
which led approver let's say me to prove
you statements about a cigarette we
built a secret without actually giving
up that secret so I can prove you that I
know a secret and something about that
secret without revealing that secret so
this is how it works in general but an
easy way to understand the intuition
beyond zero knowledge proof it's
actually the game with these two pens so
I will give you these two pens and the
idea is that you are color blind and you
cannot distinguish which one is the red
and which one is the blue but you don't
believe me you think that actually there
are no way to distinguish this pen and
now I would like to prove you that these
pens are actually invisible without
giving away the information of which one
is the blue and which one is the red so
I don't want you to know which one is
the red which one is the blue but still
be sure that you believe me when I say
one these two are not equal so how does
it work so I will give you these two
pens in random order and now I will you
I will ask you to put it behind your
back and to swap your aunt either you do
either you don't randomly as far as I'm
concerned now I don't know if this is
blue or this is but there is actually
pencil on the same you are color blind
okay this thing is that okay so pudding
is behind the back you swap her or you
don't
and now I can tell you you didn't swap
the pens so
now
you actually kind of believe me but
you're not really sure because I could
have simply said it at random I had a
50% chances to guess to get the right
answer so let's say you do it again all
right
okay going behind my back and yeah now I
can say you swap the pen so now you're a
little bit more convinced because you
know that I could have cheatin only with
a chance of 25% and that's the idea
behind your mole is proof we can repeat
that experiment as often as you like
decreasing the probability to 12.5% and
so on until you're fully convinced that
I couldn't have cheatin about that this
is the first example and have a second
one to make things absolutely clear it's
about these cards so let's say that we
have a classic card deck of 52 cards and
I'll take like one randomly from this
and now I would like to prove you that
this card is actually red but I don't
want to give away the information about
the number on that card and nothing else
about that how does it works to convince
you about that without giving away the
number so I will simply put that here so
you can see it and I take the other one
now what I will do is I will show you
exactly 26 cards that are actually black
so now you can count them and if you do
you will notice that if there are here
26 cards which are black this one here
must be right so this is our nice
example on how you know this works and
the intuition beyond to make the think a
little bit a little bit more
mathematical for the people that may
like it you knowledge proofs actually
have three criteria if the protocol
respect is true criteria you can say
okay I did as you knowledge proof the
first is correctness it simply stated
that if both people are honest so if I'm
honest and you are honest everything
works fine the second one is soundness
it's also kind of abuse it means that if
I don't know the secret I cannot prove
the statement and I cannot prove that I
know the secret so with the example of
before if I couldn't recognize the
depends I wouldn't be able to tell you
if you swap another band behind you have
your hand and the third one is what
makes the wall point of having zero
knowledge proof is the is the
characteristic called zero knowledge in
itself it means that I am following the
protocol you learn nothing more than the
statement that I wanted to prove you so
in the example of the card you learn
nothing more that the card here is
actually read nothing no side
information that's the world point how
can you use your knowledge proofs in the
real life so an example for that a very
nice one is about a voting how to use
zero knowledge proof to make
avoiding works fine so let's say that we
want to vote for an election which has
two candidates two candidates are the
pen that we had before and have two
envelopes here and my vote let's say
once you vote for the pen on the right
here what I do is I'll write a 1 here
and 0 here now I put my vote inside VN
Roth and putting the vote inside the
envelope actually means and Crick
encrypting them using a specific
specific type of scheme which is not the
scope of that video so remote one which
means I want to vote for pen blue here
and 0 I don't want to vote for this
panel here now how does it works you do
the same ok so I have to write 1 0 1 and
0 and you put them here do you have to
look away at this time yes
and so everybody does its voting such
way the envelope means that the vote are
encrypted the idea is that at the end we
use protocol to aggregate the results
inside all the envelope without
revealing particularly each vote we will
only reveal the Sun all the vote having
blue and all the votes for red but if we
do that
there is many way that we the voter can
cheat the first thing we could do
actually is not write 0 on 1 and the
election it's all about voting for
exactly one candidate not both and
none of them so the first year knowledge
proved we could include inside that
eroding protocol is the proof that the
sum of our votes so the sum of the thing
that are inside your envelope sum up to
1 which means you voted for exactly one
candidate but now imagine that you were
about cheating and what you did was you
put minus 1 in one envelop and plus 2 in
the other one the sum is still 1 but you
could not do that so a second your
knowledge proof you should add to the
protocol is the proof that then the
encrypted values are binary so either 0
or 1 so it makes to zero knowledge proof
and now let's say another one which is
also optional let's say for instance
that I know nothing about Penn's politic
but I do know that you know a lot about
it so what could I do is I take your
envelope you previous vote I copy/paste
it without knowing what's inside and
then I vote it on top of it so what I do
the third zero knowledge proof would be
to prove that I actually know the inside
of the envelope that actually know what
am i voting for and this mitigates the
the three problems that we could have
naive avoiding this is one of the
example and this could be applicated
actually in the same way for assigning
petitions online for petitioning system
so it's an idea where you can vote
electronically so having the benefits of
technology without giving away your
privacy when you mentioned looking
inside and checking that things are
binary and add up to one people could
look inside those anyway could they or
is there a special protocol no so
actually the envelope here are not
really envelope these are encryption of
what is inside so there is no way to
decrypt it and no one is really willing
to and has not the possibility to
decrypt each single vote you can only
decrypt once all devoted all the votes
have been summed up so there is no way
to recover which person voted for which
a pen at the end there is only way to
know that the person actually did a
binary vote which is also some up to 1
and that he knew the content of the vote
this is positive encryption protocol as
yeah the second part is part of the zero
protocol that comes over and works with
the encryption protocol the idea is that
the fact that the vote is binary is your
statement but the votes content is your
secret so still in the definition with
your knowledge proof about proving you
statements about the secret without
revealing in the secret so for instance
the fact that the card is read back in
our cars example but not what the
numbers right exactly
yes that's an example or also the secret
is my vote so the secret is is it zero
or one I don't tell you that but I want
to tell you the statement that the piece
binary
it then there will be no energy cost to
computing no energy core no energy cost
because here's the fascinating thing
what costs the energy is not the
computation itself it's a raising
information